video game exploits have been around for
ages now and they range from the awesome
to the superbly
annoying since the division has just
decided to nerf bullet King it's
exploitable respawning boss I figured we
talked about a few times the game has
decided to enjoy the exploits and
glitches that games have to offer and
probably insisted it wasn't cheating
the division may be losing its loot cave
but we should talk about why the term
exists in the first place and that is
destiny for the uninitiated the infamous
destiny loot cave was an enemy spawn
zone in the old Russia location where
you could stand in one spot and fire
into a cave entrance farming endlessly
respawning low-level grunts the drops
and experience so long as you capture
distance there was even a very specific
Boulder you were expected to stand
behind if you wanted to join stranger
than shooting up the joint in order to
avoid blocking the spawn zone Bungie
eventually patched through the enemy
respond out but added a pile of charred
enemy remains to the cave alluding to
the exploit from beyond the bug fix
perhaps one of gaming's most infamous
exploits was the glitchy pokemon missing
though from pokemon red and flick this
one is a little complicated so I'll try
to go through it slowly first you talk
to an old man in the north of Viridian
City who teaches you have to catch
pokemon then you use a Pokemon who has
the fly skill to fast travel to Cinnabar
Island where you'll need a Pokemon with
the surf skills so you can swim up and
down a particular coastline to try and
trigger an encounter with the glitch
Pokemon missing know who you can catch
and has the highest base attack of any
Pokemon in the game but the most useful
side effect of the glitch in that the
sixth item in your bag is multiplied so
you can get a shitload of Master Balls
rare candies or whatever your fancy
enjoy your free [ __ ] you definitely
aren't cheating my favorite thing about
this next exploit is that a lot of
players including me found it
organically now it really does pay to be
a master thief in Skyrim but it can be
hard to get out of the watchful eye of
shopkeepers the solution Buckethead I
remember originally finding this one
when I got out of jail and needed to get
my [ __ ] back from an evidence chest but
a watchful guard would not go away I
recall being absolutely chuffed when I
angled a nearby bucket over the dudes
head and made away with my stuff unseen
totally earning that criminal scum title
sadly but those two did patch this one
out too but I like to
think there are still merchants in
abandoned Skyrim games everywhere
wondering who turned the lights out you
know when an exploit gets particularly
annoying when it's in a competitive
multiplayer game a whole lot of early
first-person shooters including
counter-strike half-life and quake let
you bunnyhop that's basically where a
player jumps repeatedly while strafing
to make themselves harder to hit or in
some cases move faster than they usually
would this works because the player
gains more acceleration while strafing
to the side then they do when it's just
moving straight forward obviously this
is a huge bonus in a PvP setting
bunny-hopping is just one in a range of
FPS exploits which include Halo - super
bounces which use crouching and terrain
floors to launch you crazy high into the
air and lets you take advantage of
unfair sniper positions shortcuts in
Mario Kart games are pretty commonplace
and certainly aren't exploits that said
this particular one from Rainbow Road
was definitely not intentional Rainbow
Road in Mario Kart 64 consists of an
early shortcut where you bank left hard
shortly after starting and jump over the
rail in the first drop if you do it
successfully there's a stretch of track
you can land on which cuts out about a
third of the length of the track a
similar trick existed in the wario
stadium track where a few times a boost
over a hump and hit the side wall at the
right angle you could leap over a huge
barrier and skip half the track both of
these exploits contribute very
effectively to the adage that Mario Kart
is the fastest way to lose friends these
are just a few of the exploits that have
defined gaming from over the years so be
sure to let me know which ones I missed
out on mentioning down in that comment
section and I will see you again soon